well I like to lead with good news so
let me assure you that at no point this
evening will I read from or quote the
poet Rumi
[Music]
yeah is the sound comfortable for
everyone is the light comfortable for
everyone and are you comfortable well
you shouldn't be
the planets going to [ __ ] in a handbag
no I'm I'm
that's just my John Lilly imitation
that's not me at all a few years ago we
bought 10 acres in Hawaii and moved as
many of these Peruvian drug plants as we
could yes so that was four or five years
ago now those plants are grown and
hopefully the next time we go back to
Hawaii we'll be able to produce
ayahuasca we're calling a Hawaiian part
of my audience is part of the problem
and it's a really weird experience to
have someone come up to you after a talk
and say you know I love your stuff I
there aren't very many people I respect
and I love your stuff and I also love
and then they name two indictable morons
from the land of woowoo and you think oh
my god you know this person has no power
of discrimination whatsoever I am a
pearl placed among swine either they're
wrong or I'm wrong in any case there's
enough wrong around to be disturbing
because what you want to do it is being
understood the
Ellis inian mysteries the mysteries
which were practiced on the plane
outside of Athens every year for over
2,000 years and everybody who was
anybody in the ancient world made the
journey too elusive to celebrate the
greater mysteries it was extraordinarily
powerful for the ancient world
eventually it was destroyed alaric the
visigoth
who was a barbarian but that didn't stop
him from being a convert to Christianity
alaric the visigoth burned a lusus on
his way to north africa to burn other
things but when I listen to recordings
of this glossolalia down
I have makes me very uncomfortable and I
wonder what could possibly be the matter
with me that ice placed so much emphasis
on this and I've noticed you know it'll
clear most rooms in a hurry it's all
people are with it you know and they say
hello it's far out all this stuff and
then you play it and they say well no I
forgot to go do something they draw back
it seems too quirky too quirky Oh
OHP so it's a tremendous empowerment for
eccentricity and basically my whole
career is based on eccentricity one of
the most fearful questions to come my
way is when I'm riding on airplanes to
some situation like this and someone
sits down beside me and says so what do
you do
and I usually I try to escape I say and
this is always a horribly weak thing I
say oh I write book and then they say oh
well what do you write books about and
then we move into the realm of pure lie
I usually say travel and we know from
laboratory experiments that if you set
monkeys in a situation where they can
smoke DMT by just walking up to a
pipette and taking a hit that 20% of the
monkeys will refuse food and water in
preference to that
we'd rather be stone and then culture
seems to step in to put the nails in the
coffin to completely knee autumn eyes
you and so we have you know sixty
five-year-old men running around in
sweatpants and Nike running shoes and
everybody having their butt tucked and
their tits pump than all of this well
what is this this is a culture of youth
the youth values only the youthful body
only the youthful vigor is is worth
talking about and it's cell you know if
you can get people really neurotically
twisted around this idea then instead of
life being an unfoldment into wisdom
it's an anxiety producing fall away from
a perfect state of youth which can only
then be approached through dyeing your
hair wearing certain cologne certain
brands of clothes psychotherapy yada
yada yada
yes I'll repeat this and strengthen once
again my case to the guy who owns the
company that he should pay me for god
sake if you want a catalog of extremely
rare and useful psychoactive and magical
plants probably the most complete in the
world the company is called of the
jungle PL box one a201 Sebastopol se bas
topo2 Liffe or Nia
nine five four seven two right and ask
for a catalog
and tell them George Bush sent you no
I'm teasing don't tell them that they
won't send you the catalog in in
Colombia once I saw a graffiti and it on
my Spanish I can't get it right but what
it was there was a picture of a mushroom
and it said without this you are not
yourself
[Laughter]
that's his I'm out of here
[Laughter]